we went to the set of the HBO series
deduce where they have a new job called
intimacy coordinators ya star Emily
Meade made sure of it I'm on a show
about the sex industry I was thinking
about all the times I felt uncomfortable
in my career especially when it comes to
filming sexual scenes I went to HBO and
they instantly hired Alicia who's our
intimacy coordinator I'm there to have
the uncomfortable conversations that no
one wants to have and making sure that
that things are set and boundaries
aren't getting crossed I'm trying to do
my job here Alicia rodas is now on set
of HBO's of the deuce for every nude
scene her job includes being both an
actor's advocate and choreographer the
first scene I had with her I was
actually kissing someone he had to touch
my breasts at one point Alicia came in
and explained to him that if he just
bent his fingers in a certain way it
would actually sell touching my breasts
while actually having to do it less
Alicia also keeps a fully stocked kit on
set with some surprising contents and it
includes pretty much every kind of
breath mint you can think of and gum and
spray I have lots of hand sanitizer nude
thongs padding she has pretty much every
level of thickness divider that you can
either hide in sheets little like almost
like a bicycle see she has taped many
things to my crotch area tissues baby
wipes I just try to bring a full kit
with me every time this has been
something that I don't think anyone ever
knew that they needed but truly it's
times up and it appears that other shows
are gonna follow the lead of the do CG
found out that big little lives will
likely use an intimacy coordinator when
they have sexual scenes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]